LAUNCHING ANY NEW ASSAULTS.
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE"
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW IS HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
CONGRESSMEN, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
TODAY PELOSI -- HE SAW THAT
CLIP, WAS VISIBLY ANNOYED.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO SOME THE
ARTICLES, WHAT'S GOING ON?
SHE SEEMED VERY FRUSTRATED IN
THIS POSITION.
WHAT'S OUR CALCULATION?
WHAT IS THE PRO AND CON FOR HER
HERE?
>> WELL, SHE HAS NO CON.
SHE IS GOING TO FAIL AT THIS.
SHE HAS ALREADY FAILED.
NOW'S NOT JUST REPUBLICANS,
DEMOCRATS SENATORS.
WAS EVEN WORSE IS
DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
THIS IS OUR HOME SENATOR, HER
HOMETOWN SENATOR FROM
SAN FRANCISCO.
SHE LITERALLY SAID IF IT IS SO
URGENT, IF YOU KEEP IT, IT LOSES
ITS URGENCY.
EITHER SEND IT OVER OR DON'T
SEND IT AT ALL.
IT'S CRUSHING HER.
>> Laura: BUT WHAT DOES THE
HOUSE DECIDES ON ITS OWN TO
SUBPOENA BOLDEN.
THIS THEORY HAS BEEN FLOATED THE
LAST 72 HOURS, THEY COULD
SUBPOENA BOLTON AND GET
INFORMATION FROM HIM AND I DON'T
KNOW, BACKFILL THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY, THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING NOW.
>> THEY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY, BUT
THEY DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
IMPORTANT ENOUGH, THAT WAS SO
URGENT, THEY HAD ENOUGH
INFORMATION, LO AND BEHOLD, BUT
WHEN IT WENT TO THE FLOOR, IT WS
NOT THERE.
HER THEY KNOW THE CASE IS SO
WEAK, IT'S LIKE SHE'S EMBARRASSD
OF IT.
>> Laura: TO THE IRAN ISSUE,
DEMOCRATS CAME OUT OF THE
ADMINISTERS BRIEFINGS BREATHING
STEADY ON CAPITOL HILL AND WERE
ALL PRETTY MUCH SINGING THE SAME
TUNE.
WATCH.
>> I WAS DEEPLY SURPRISED AT THE
LACK OF INFORMATION PRESENTED BY
THE ADMINISTRATION REGARDING A
SPECIFIC, IMMINENT THREAT.
>> THERE WAS NO RAW EVIDENCE
PRESENTED THAT THERE WAS AN
IMMINENT THREAT.
>> I WAS UTTERLY UNPERSUADED
ABOUT ANY EVIDENCE ABOUT THE
IMMINENCE OF A THREAT THAT WAS
NEW OR COMPELLING.
>> Laura: UM, ARE THEY ALL LIE
AND?
MIKE LEE IS ESSENTIALLY SAYING
THE SAME THING AS ALL OF THESE
DEMOCRATS, A CONSERVATIVE FROM
UTAH.
>> IT IS A TOP-SECRET HEARING,
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SAYING FOR ONE MOMENT TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC -- THEY DON'T
HAVE TO BE IN THAT MEETING --
MORE THAN 600 AMERICAN SOLDIERS
HAVE BEEN KILLED BY THIS
INDIVIDUAL.
THEY KILLED AN AMERICAN.
THEY TOOK DOWN A DRONE.
THEY BOMBED TANKERS, THEY BOMBED
SAUDI ARABIA'S REFINERY.
THEY TOOK AFTER OUR EMBASSY.
AND SOMEHOW, IT'S ALSO
ESCALATING SOMETHING?
I THINK THE WAY THE PRESIDENT
HANDLED THIS WAS MASTERFUL.
IT'S LIKE A CHESS GAME, AND
THESE PEOPLE DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IN THE SOCIAL IS DEMOCRATS ARE
DEFENDING IRAN OVER DEFENDING
AMERICA.
>> Laura: MIKE LEE SAID IT WAS
THE WORST BRIEFING HE HAD EVER
SEEN BASICALLY STATING
CONCLUSORY COMMENTS ABOUT THE
IMMINENCE WITHOUT ACTUAL FACTS
OF TIME, PLACE, MANNER, WHAT'S
THING TO HAPPEN.
>> I WISH I COULD SHARE WITH YOU
WHAT WAS SAID.
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU THINK HE
IS SAYING THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY HE WAS
SAYING THAT.
I WAS NOT IN THE SENATE
BRIEFING, I WAS IN THE HOUSE
BREATHING.
>> Laura: IT MUST HAVE BEEN
THE SAME.
>> THE SAME MEMBERS FROM CA,
SECRETARY --
>> Laura: WITH A
CONDESCENDING?
>> NOT AT ALL.
WITH INTEREST INCOME IF I COULD
ONLY SHARE, THE WAY PEOPLE ASK
QUESTIONS AND COME BACK, THEY
WOULD GET THE ANSWER THEY ASKEDA
WOULD GET THE ANSWER THEY ASKEDD
THEY TRY TO COME BACK, LIKE
THEY COULDN'T HEAR IT.
IT WAS ANSWERED, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT WAS EMBARRASSING, BECAUSE
HERE THEY ARE, THEY WANT TO
DEFEND THIS TERRORIST.
HE'S A BAD GUY, BUT.
I WANT TO HEAR DEMOCRATS SAY,
HE'S A BAD GUY BECAUSE HE KILLED
AMERICANS, BECAUSE HE WENT AFTER
OUR EMBASSY, BECAUSE HE KILLED
ANOTHER AMERICAN, BECAUSE HE
WENT AFTER THE TANKERS.
>> Laura: AFTER PLAYING THE
TACTICS OF PERPETUAL RESISTANCE
FOR THREE YEARS NOW, IT'S
AMAZING TO SEE AND HEAR THE
DEMOCRATS CLAIMING THAT IT IS
THE PRESIDENT AND WANTS TO
DIVIDE THE COUNTRY AT A TIME
LIKE THIS, BUT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED.
LEON PANETTA WAS A PRETTY
WELL-RESPECTED GUY COME ON WITH
ANDERSON COOPER.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THIS MOMENT OF POTENTIAL
NATIONAL UNITY AND NATIONAL,
KIND OF RELIEF, HE YOU KNOW,
CHOSE IT, LAY IT ON, ATTACKED
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
>> HE'S ALMOST DELIBERATELY
TRIED TO SPLIT THIS COUNTRY
APART.
ALL HE CARES ABOUT IS WHETHER OR
NOT HIS SUPPORTERS CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT HIM.
I THINK THAT'S A SERIOUS
MISTAKE.
>> Laura: SO, DID THE
PRESIDENT MISS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING THE NATION
TOGETHER TODAY?
>> NO, I THINK WHAT HE DID WAS
HE MADE THIS WORLD SAFER.
THINK FOR A MOMENT, WHAT IF WE
WERE ABLE TO STOP BIN LADEN
BEFORE 9/11 HAPPENED?
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY MORE PEOPLE
ARE SAFE.
AND THINK ABOUT HISTORY WILL
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE BECAUSE
OF HOW STRONG THIS PRESIDENT
ACTED.
HE HELD RESTRAINT WHEN A DRONE
WENT DOWN, BUT WHEN THEY KILLED
AN AMERICAN FROM A REDLINE ON
THE SAND, AND HE ACTUALLY ACTED.
>> Laura: I WOULD SAY, WHAT IF
WE COULD HAVE KNOCKED OUT SADDAM
BEFORE HE WENT TO WAR AGAIN
BECAUSE MEGAN WHEN HE TRAVELED
TO KUWAIT, KNOCK HIM OUT.
>> EXACTLY.
THIS IS SUCH A JOKE, THEY ARE
BRINGING HIM UNDER WHAT IS
CALLED A CALM RESOLUTION.
>> Laura: TOMORROW.
>> YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY ARE BRINGING IT UP, IT IS
CON RESOLUTION, THE SAME KIND OF
RESOLUTION WE USE TO DO A SOAP
BOX DERBY ON CAPITOL HILL.
IT DOESN'T GO TO THE PRESIDENT.
IT MEANS NOTHING.
>> Laura: SO THEY ARE DOING IT
TOO, WHAT?
FOR WHAT PURPOSE?
>> I DON'T KNOW, TO APPEASE THE
SOCIAL SPACE, BUT HAS NO POWER,
NO MEETING, IT EQUAL TO A
SOAP BOX DERBY.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN ALISA
SLOTKIN, THE SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION --
>> SHE SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED.
>> Laura: IT THIS IS A
BATTLEGROUND STATE.
EVERYONE WATCHING MICHIGAN, THIS
IS YOUR CONGRESSWOMAN.
>> WE SHOULD COME AS A BODY, BE
DISCUSSING AND DEBATING IF THERE
IS EVEN A RISK OF US GOING INTO
WAR WITH IRAN.
I JUST WANTED TO PUT THE MARKER
DOWN AND BE VERY, VERY CLEAR
BECAUSE WE ARE PASS THIS MOMENT,
DOESN'T MEAN CONGRESS HAS A
RIGHT TO ABDICATE ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> Laura: VERY HIGH-MINDED,
CONGRESSMEN.
>> SHE KNOWS BETTER THAN THIS,
IF YOU READ HER BACKGROUND.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT IS MOST
INTERESTING?
SHE IS ALLOWING HER NAME TO BE
USED AS A TRICK.
WITH A RESOLUTION THAT MEANS
NOTHING, IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
MEANING WHATSOEVER, AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO PLAY SOMETHING UP, AND
THEN THEY'RE TRYING TO TIE THE
HANDS, AND ARE THEY FORGETTING
WHAT IRAN HAS DONE TO THE
AMERICAN SOLDIER?
>> Laura: SHE KNOWS, SHE
SERVED IN IRAQ AND THE CIA.
SHE SERVED OUR COUNTRY.
>> WHAT IS THE SPEAKER DOING TO
THESE NEW MEMBERS?
WALKING THEM OFF THE CLIFF ON
IMPEACHMENT, NOW DEFENDING IRAN
OVER DEFENDING AMERICA.
>> Laura: AOC PLUS THREE WERE
FUN TO WATCH.
>> DID YOU WATCH THEM LAUGH
DURING THE HEARING?
>> Laura: SHEILA JACKSON LEE
IS ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
CASUALTIES.
I WILL GIVE HER CREDIT, SHE WAS
TALKING WITH POTENTIAL FOR
CASUALTIES, AND THE OTHER ONES
ARE LAUGHING IN THE BACKGROUND,
ARE LAUGHING IN THE BACKGROUND.
>> ON 9/11, SOME PEOPLE DID SOME
THINGS, REMEMBER WHAT SHE SAID
ABOUT 9/11?
>> Laura: I ALREADY HAVE A
STOMACH ACHE.